you want to talk about Tom Brady's
second retirement sad sad sad sad day
okay I was asking Charlemagne about this
and I'm curious what you guys think like
do you do you really think that he threw
away his marriage for one more year
that's the narrative that's out there my
suspicion is the marriage was already
shaky and and he was like I'm not gonna
sacrifice playing another year for
something I don't think I can salvage
like I want to play another year I'm not
going to not do that and then we get
divorced anyway yeah I can't fathom that
they had the best marriage ever and
because he wanted to play one more year
they're like now it's done yeah I want
him to keep playing for that reason
because it costs your marriage but then
I thought about it to your point I was
like oh probably he retired and then he
was like the fact that I want I don't
want to be here anymore probably means
we're done like if I'm that willing to
go back to football that lets me know me
not having football and just being with
you it's not working so I think he went
back to football knowing it's probably
going to cost me my marriage but it's
not what I thought it was and she
probably said the same thing having him
home is probably not what I thought it
was are they fully divorced divorced
full yeah settled everything oh it's
settled yeah her good days
bro she's still cooking I don't know
what you're talking about son I don't
know if you've seen the recent pictures
still the mother of the kids bruh oh
[__]
come on that now she was down in uh in
Costa Rica in Santa Teresa yeah where we
went oh you met you saw her no I didn't
see her but she goes down there a lot
apparently like and she was down there
with the trainers all these girls get
with the trainer what is up with that
trying to make sense why because it's
someone that's got Authority they
typically look good and on top of that
you're doing hard work together yeah
that's to make your brain feel better
every time endorphin release every time
you see this guy caused by him and he
makes feeling your best when you're
around him yeah and he's good looking
testosterone all over this man all up in
this man it makes sense to me that
you're just doing Fitness and they've
already broke that barrier because like
the the touching barrier physical it's
like yeah that's why you got to be like
a eunuch that's what they did back in
the day right what they do back like if
you were like a [__] Apprentice to
the queen or whatever they chopped your
balls off so like that makes more sense
I thought the trainers back in the day
had no balls that's what we need to do
now yeah but they need a testosterone
why do you need testosterone like gray
worm in Game of Thrones yeah exactly
well because I'm not going to listen if
you don't got tested if you look like a
eunuch I'm not going to take your advice
on Fitness why not it'd be like Yoda
like Yoda is not the most fit guy
Yoda's advice if Yoda was training you
wouldn't listen to him no he's white he
would be Anakin for sure
uh Harrison Ford
that's what miles what did Eric who is
Harrison Ford yeah
I don't need that little [__] for
[__] yeah but you're a guy also that
thing if some if there's like if there's
a guy I guess I wouldn't even want a guy
training my wife in the first place yeah
I don't want a guy training my wife
sorry man you it's a segue but you might
respect this as a actor who doesn't
really like doing his lines and they're
seeing in one of those Star Wars where
Princess Leia says I love you and Han
Solo goes I know he was supposed to say
I love you too and something mushy and
Aries before was like my character ain't
there's no [__] he ain't saying that so
she goes I love you and then he just
goes I know and then they get frozen or
whatever the [__] oh really which I
thought you might respect bro yeah see
Harrison Ford of Legend what would Yoda
have done
oh that's a good question in a riddle or
something yeah yeah oh [__] but
something wise though yeah yeah yeah
yeah but be honest your girl comes home
she's like oh yeah I got a trainer we're
doing one-on-one sessions it's this guy
and then shows you a picture of some
handsome strapping guy nope yeah I mean
my girl does have a male trainer but if
it's a group setting that's fine nah
yeah it's just one-on-one I mean you got
to do something I do have to do
something about that I had a quick
comedy when you're 44. that's what you
got to do
you got six years [__] but you also
don't want you don't want her to get out
of shape or you don't want to like
discourage her you know what I mean if
she's having a lot of fun with Fitness
you don't want to destroy the whole
thing now she's she is a female trainer
but I like that see there you go yeah
that's good make sure she's straight
though because if she's gay it's even
more yeah yeah I'll wait rather uh get a
male trainer than a gay female trainer
when why because a gay female trainer
knows how they got the wrist bruh son
you want some rich MJ being your [__]
trainer up bro
she's gonna come with all that thermopod
[__] and she'll be like yeah yeah I
don't care
about him I don't care I see your value
Beyond him I don't care I don't care and
you're not gonna do nothing to me oh
yeah oh yeah
he's right he's trying to talk it yeah
no no I don't care about that oh no you
you're saying that she's gonna Oh I
thought she's trying to hook up with my
girl she's trying to just sabotage our
relationship or nothing yeah but I would
say try
yeah but like if I don't care like even
if they did I wouldn't I don't know
okay now we're talking now it's a whole
different ball okay I wouldn't care that
much no like I listen ideally it's not
that but if I had to choose between like
a guy or a girl of course yeah I don't
know I don't know oh come on you would
you rather you just agreed with me yeah
and then he put it a different scenario
yeah and now I'm old then he was just
talking about Fitness you know yeah you
just have a fitness okay I'm just saying
someone having sex with your wife you
would rather be a girl than a guy oh
yeah sure but I think the girl would
take if you get a female trainer it's
not just sex she's taking that girl
emotionally from you
[Music]
um
I think yeah that Muslims got it bro
they could be upset they upset about the
same [__] yeah y'all should talk this
out yeah like you're she's going now you
don't spend enough time with me because
you're with her and it's like you know
who could really relate to this
um work that amongst yourselves I think
there's something to this yeah I think
so like I don't even know if they really
hate each other like that
do you know what I'm saying like I don't
I think that they're like competitive
but they don't hate each other it's like
F1 drivers do you know what I mean like
they all try to jockey for positions
it's like Brady and Manning yeah exactly
but they don't hate they relate the most
yeah yeah they get it they [__] know
the life it's like presidents you're not
like all presidents just hang out with
each other because they're the only ones
who know what it's like yeah that's what
it is
[Laughter]
I don't want to deal with that stress
that seems like too much stress but you
haven't you'd rather a [__] dude over
a girl
crazy bro I thought I would y'all making
me question myself now yeah okay you
should questions
but y'all really making me feel insecure
about my decision so
[__] are you so secure about it that
you're called a guy yeah that's a
trainer guy
man I don't know bro I just think the
girl's gonna get in there more deeply
you just agreed with me yeah but then he
made what was what he was thinking about
I know I was bugging that was one of the
craziest things yeah you see okay I was
bugging too there you go get off me yeah
there we go thank God but yeah all I had
to say I don't think him going back for
another season actually like ended it I
think that was this the beginning of the
end I don't even know what we talking
here
I was like who's going back
no that's right yeah I don't think
that's the thing that there's no [__]
way I think it's like when you're all
your kids move out and then you realize
like what you have in your relationship
yeah I think it's the same thing like
you guys done with his career and he
goes okay where's our relationship at
yeah not in a good place so I don't
think it was the one additional season I
think it was the 20 Seasons before that
that slowly eroded things away and other
communication issues more than 20
Seasons held it together and then when
it was finally home
it really sucks well that's we suck
together that's the thing is like she's
got her career she's making crazy money
yeah so she's busy she got a full-time
job she's busy as [__] she's flying
around the world doing all this fashion
[__] okay he's got his career he's busy
as [__] you're the quarterback yeah
right and he he was more obsessive than
everyone of course all year so it's like
there's no time yeah think about how
little time we have yeah there's no way
that time yeah right so of course you
get along of course you think you do oh
two good looking people let's see each
other once a month and have children
together oh my God how do you manage
that right of course you're gonna be
able to keep the marriage together and
then like you said the second you stop
playing
so we're together too much this don't
work maybe stay at the house for a while
yeah oh God he's implies some crazy [__]
we should have known that marriage is
over like you having some other dude
ABC wild one you having a wild dude come
live with us so you can win a
championship yeah her children are here
yo let's go home I'm sure he's number
one I have like guys over because then
like she just has to do everything and
we just have the fun like yeah yeah
that's why miles couldn't live with me
okay that's why I'm telling you yeah you
got a domicile you got a domicile you
can't disrupt that yeah miles that's too
much testosterone that's what I'm saying
dude yeah miles coming in he's gonna
[__] up the whole thing he's gonna
ignore your wife completely
that's over your wife is probably like
thank God
that's honestly true that's honestly a
great point